c'est un dispositif qui est à la hauteur
de l'événement sportif de cette année
cette coupe du monde que vous pourrez
suivre sur nos trois antennes en
télévision en radio et évidemment sur
nos réseaux sociaux et notre site
internet
ces matchs de foot seront à suivre en
direct avec notamment le 15 le premier
match que vous pourrez suivre jusqu'à la
finale puisque la finale sera diffusée
en direct sur martinique la première le
15 juillet le dimanche 15 juillet en
radio aussi événement cette année vous
pourrez suivre les matchs de l'équipe de
france avec notamment france pérou que
nous vous proposerons au direct en radio
le 21 juin et puis bien sûr vous pourrez
quel que soit l'endroit où vous vous
trouverez suivre les événements sportifs
le rendez vous sportif de l'année avec
nos réseaux sociaux avec internet avec
l'équipe le web d'outre-mer première et
l'équipe web de martinique la première
qui travaillera main dans la main pour
pouvoir nous donner tous les grands
rendez vous et éventuellement les à
côtés puisque souvenez-vous nous allons
mettre en place une fan zone
une émission qui sera en direct en
télévision et sur nos réseaux sociaux et
qui sera diffusée en direct juste avant
chaque match qui vous sera retransmis
sur notre antenne martinique la première
rendez vous donc le 15 à partir de 14h
pour suivre ce premier match de foot
teennick la première vous fera vibrer
pour vivre ce grand moment qui est la
finale de cette coupe du monde 2018
ce sera le dimanche 15 juillet et ce
sera à suivre sur l'ensemble de notre
réseau à partir de 11h du matin
vous aurez 14 matchs dont la finale qui
nous diffuserons en direct sur
martinique la première